- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation
ผมชื่อ John Watrous เป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิค
ด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM Quantum
นี่เป็นบทเรียนที่สองของซีรีส์นี้ ถ้ายังไม่ได้ดู
บทเรียนแรก อย่าลืมไปดูกันก่อนนะ
เราจะต่อยอดจากสิ่งที่พูดถึง
ในบทเรียนแรกโดยตรง ดังนั้นสำคัญมากที่ต้อง
เข้าใจเนื้อหานั้นก่อนเข้าบทเรียนนี้
นอกจากนี้ ซีรีส์นี้
มีเนื้อหาแบบตำราเรียนเพิ่มเติมนอกเหนือจากวิดีโอ แล้วก็หาลิงก์
ไปยังเนื้อหาตำราเรียนได้
ในรายละเอียดวิดีโอ นี่คือบทเรียนที่สองของ
ยูนิตที่หนึ่งของซีรีส์นี้
ยูนิตที่หนึ่งครอบคลุมพื้นฐาน
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว เราพูดถึงข้อมูลควอนตัมในบริบทของระบบเดี่ยว หมายความว่าเรามีระบบเดียว
ที่เก็บข้อมูล
แล้วเราก็อธิบายว่า
มันทำงานยังไงแบบแยกเดี่ยว
เราใช้เวลาพอสมควรกับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิก เป็นหลักเพื่อสร้างจุดอ้างอิงและเน้นให้เห็น
ความคล้ายกันทางคณิตศาสตร์
ระหว่างข้อมูลควอนตัมกับข้อมูลคลาสสิก
เรายังได้เห็นว่าสถานะควอนตัมสามารถแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์ได้ โดยเฉพาะเวกเตอร์ที่มี
ค่าเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนและมีนอร์มแบบยูคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง
แล้วเราก็พูดถึงการวัดแบบ
standard basis กับการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารี
ในบทเรียนนี้ เราจะขยายมุมมอง
ไปสู่หลายระบบ ซึ่งแต่ละระบบสามารถ
เก็บข้อมูลควอนตัมได้
นี่ไม่ใช่แค่เรื่องของการบอกว่าแต่ละระบบ
ทำงานอย่างที่เราพูดถึงครั้งที่แล้ว มันมีความรู้สึกว่าส่วนรวม
นั้นยิ่งใหญ่กว่าผลรวมของส่วนประกอบ แล้วนี่ก็เป็นจริงกับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิกเมื่อมีความน่าจะเป็นเข้ามาเกี่ยวด้วย
หลายระบบสามารถ
โต้ตอบกันได้ แล้วก็สามารถมีความสัมพันธ์
กันได้ เช่น ในบริบทควอนตัม รวมถึงความเป็นไปได้
ที่ระบบจะพัวพัน ซึ่งเป็นคำที่
อาจจะเคยได้ยินมาก่อน
การพัวพันเป็นปรากฏการณ์
ที่สำคัญมากในข้อมูลควอนตัม แล้วเราจะมีเรื่องอีกเยอะที่จะพูดถึงเมื่อซีรีส์ดำเนินต่อไป
มีหลักการง่ายๆ อย่างหนึ่งที่ให้เราเข้าใจได้ค่อนข้างมากในการคิดและ
ทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมสำหรับหลายระบบ
ก็คือเราสามารถ
เอาสองระบบหรือมากกว่านั้นมารวมกัน หรือแค่คิดในเชิงแนวคิด
ว่ามันอยู่ด้วยกัน
แล้วมองว่ามันรวมกัน
เป็นระบบประกอบเดียว
แล้วเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ระบบประกอบแบบนี้ เหมือนว่ามันเป็นระบบเดียว เราก็ต้องยอมรับว่ามันต้องอธิบายในแบบที่สอดคล้อง
กับทุกอย่างที่เราเรียนรู้
ในบทเรียนที่แล้วเรื่องระบบเดี่ยว
เราจะเห็นว่ามันทำงานยังไง
แล้วก็การอธิบายข้อมูลควอนตัม
จากหลายระบบเกิดขึ้นอย่างเป็นธรรมชาติจากวิธีที่มันทำงานสำหรับระบบเดี่ยว
จากหลักการเดียวนี้ นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน ซึ่งบังเอิญเหมือนกับภาพรวมของบทเรียนที่แล้วเป๊ะ
แต่คราวนี้เราจะ
เน้นที่หลายระบบแทนที่จะเป็นระบบเดี่ยว
เหมือนกับที่เราทำในบทเรียนที่แล้ว และด้วยเหตุผลเดียวกัน เราจะเริ่มด้วย
ข้อมูลคลาสสิก
อีกครั้ง เราจะเห็น
ความคล้ายกันอย่างมากระหว่างวิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัม
กับข้อมูลคลาสสิกทำงานในระดับคณิตศาสตร์
เราจะไม่ค่อยเน้น
ที่ข้อมูลคลาสสิกมากนัก หรือเริ่มแต่ละบทเรียนในซีรีส์ด้วยข้อมูลคลาสสิกแบบนี้
บทเรียนถัดไปจะเน้นที่ข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณมากกว่าเดิมเยอะ
แต่ตรงนี้ตอนเริ่มต้น
นี่เป็นวิธีที่สมเหตุสมผล แล้วก็กลับไปที่แนวคิดว่าการคิดเกี่ยวกับข้อมูลคลาสสิก
สามารถเป็นแหล่งชี้นำที่มีค่าสำหรับการทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัม
เราจะพูดถึง
แนวคิดสำคัญของ tensor product ใน
ส่วนนี้ของบทเรียนด้วย
Tensor product สำคัญมากในข้อมูลควอนตัม แต่มันก็ปรากฏใน
บริบทคลาสสิกเช่นกัน
จากนั้นเราจะไปต่อที่ข้อมูลควอนตัม แล้วก็เหมือนในบทเรียนที่แล้ว เราจะพูดถึงสถานะควอนตัม
การวัดแบบ standard basis
และการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารี คราวนี้
สำหรับหลายระบบ
เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดถึง
สถานะคลาสสิกของหลายระบบ
ย้อนกลับจากบทเรียนที่แล้ว
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบคือ
โครงแบบของระบบนั้นที่สามารถจดจำและ
อธิบายได้อย่างชัดเจน
โดยไม่มีความไม่แน่นอนหรือข้อผิดพลาด ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ เมื่อเราพูดถึงเซตสถานะคลาสสิก
เราหมายถึงเซตจำกัดที่ไม่ว่าง
เราจะเริ่มการพูดถึง
หลายระบบโดยสมมติว่าเรามี
แค่สองระบบ X กับ Y
X มีเซตสถานะคลาสสิกบางเซตที่เราจะเรียกว่า sigma เหมือน
ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว แล้ว Y ก็มีเซตสถานะคลาสสิกบางเซต
ที่เราจะเรียกว่า gamma เซต sigma กับ gamma
อาจเป็นเซตเดียวกันหรือต่างกันก็ได้
แต่เราตั้งชื่อต่างกัน ไม่ใช่แค่เพราะมัน
อาจเป็นเซตที่ต่างกัน แต่ยังเพราะจะช่วย
ให้เราเข้าใจชัดเจนขึ้นถ้าตั้งชื่อต่างกัน
เราจะพบว่ามัน
ง่ายมากที่จะขยายการพูดคุยทั้งหมดจากสองระบบไปเป็นจำนวนกี่ระบบก็ได้ แต่
โดยเริ่มจากสองระบบ
เราสามารถเน้นที่แนวคิดพื้นฐานได้โดยไม่ต้องจมอยู่กับรายละเอียด
ทีนี้ลองจินตนาการว่าเรา
วาง X กับ Y ไว้ข้างกัน โดย X อยู่ซ้ายกับ Y อยู่ขวา แล้วเรามองสองระบบนี้ด้วยกัน
เหมือนว่ามันรวมเป็นระบบประกอบเดียว
เพื่อตั้งชื่อระบบใหม่นี้ เราสามารถเขียนเป็น
คู่อันดับแบบนี้ หรือแค่วาง
ตัวอักษรสองตัวไว้ติดกันแบบนี้
ทั้งสองแบบเป็นเรื่องปกติ แล้ว
เราก็เลือกแบบไหนก็ได้หรือแบบที่สะดวกกว่า
ไม่ว่ายังไง เราจะอ่านว่า XY
คำถามที่เป็นธรรมชาติมาก
ที่จะถามตรงนี้คือ สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบประกอบใหม่ XY นี้คืออะไร?
คำตอบของคำถามนั้นคือ เซตสถานะคลาสสิกของ XY คือผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของ
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกทั้งสอง
sigma กับ gamma ซึ่ง
เห็นนิยามได้ตรงนี้
ณ เวลาหนึ่ง X มีสถานะคลาสสิกบางอัน
ซึ่งเป็นสมาชิกของ sigma แล้ว Y ก็มีสถานะคลาสสิกบางอัน
ซึ่งเป็นสมาชิกของ gamma
แล้วเราก็แค่คิดถึง
สองสถานะนี้ด้วยกันเหมือนว่ามันรวมเป็นสถานะเดียว แล้วนั่นก็เป็นแนวคิดที่แท้จริง
ที่ผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนจับได้ เรามีสองสมาชิก
หนึ่งจากแต่ละเซตของเรา แล้วเราต้องการคิดถึง
สองสมาชิกนี้ด้วยกัน
เหมือนว่ามันรวมเป็นสมาชิก
เดียวจากเซตเดียว
ให้ชัดเจน มีข้อสมมติตรงนี้คือ เรารู้
ว่าระบบไหนคือ X แล้วระบบไหนคือ Y
แล้วก็ไม่มีความสับสนระหว่างกัน ไม่สำคัญว่า X จะอยู่ทางซ้ายมือ
จริงๆ แล้ว Y อยู่ทางขวา
แต่ว่าสอง
ระบบนั้นแยกแยะได้ แล้วเราก็ตัดสินใจ
เรียงลำดับมันแบบนี้เพื่อที่จะได้
แยกได้ว่าอันไหนเป็นอันไหน
นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ที่ sigma เป็นตัวอักษรไบนารี แล้ว gamma เป็นเซต
ที่มีสัญลักษณ์ไพ่สี่ชนิด
ถ้า X เก็บค่าไบนารี แล้ว Y เก็บสัญลักษณ์ไพ่หนึ่งในสี่ชนิด ก็จะมีแปด
สถานะคลาสสิกที่เป็นไปได้
ของคู่ XY ซึ่ง
เห็นรายการได้ตรงนี้
สำหรับมากกว่าสองระบบ มันขยายผลได้ตรงไปตรงมา
โดยเฉพาะถ้า X1 ถึง Xn เป็นระบบที่มีเซต
สถานะคลาสสิก sigma หนึ่ง ถึง sigma n ตามลำดับ
แล้วถ้าเราจินตนาการ
จัดกลุ่ม n ระบบเข้าด้วยกันแล้วมองว่าเป็นระบบเดียว เซตสถานะคลาสสิกจะ
ให้โดยผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
ของ n เซตสถานะคลาสสิก
sigma หนึ่ง ถึง sigma n
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้บนหน้าจอ ผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
สามารถนิยามแบบนี้สำหรับจำนวนเซตเท่าไหร่ก็ได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรามีสามระบบ แล้วทุกระบบใช้ตัวอักษรไบนารีเป็นเซตสถานะคลาสสิก หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือเรามีสามบิต
ก็จะมีแปด
สถานะคลาสสิกที่เป็นไปได้ของสามบิตเมื่อ
มองรวมกันเป็นระบบเดียว แล้วก็เห็นรายการได้ตรงนี้
แต่ละระบบแยกกันสามารถ
อยู่ในสถานะศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง แล้วเราก็ไล่ทุก
ค่าผสมที่เป็นไปได้
n-tuple ของสถานะคลาสสิกสามารถเขียนเป็นสตริงได้ โดยเราตัด
วงเล็บกับจุลภาคออก อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
แล้วนี่ก็สมเหตุสมผลโดยเฉพาะเมื่อเราคิดว่า
สถานะคลาสสิกเป็นสัญลักษณ์ เหมือนในตัวอย่างทั่วไป
ของตัวอักษรไบนารี
ที่เราเอามาใช้บ่อย บางทีก็สะดวกมากที่จะทำแบบนี้ แล้วก็ทำให้
สำนวนของเราง่ายขึ้น
แล้วก็ไม่รกด้วย แนวคิดของสตริงนั้นถูกทำให้เป็นทางการ
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ผ่านผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
ดังนั้นนี่จริงๆ แค่เป็น
สัญกรณ์ทางเลือก ไม่ใช่อะไรที่ต่างกันในเชิงแนวคิด
ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่าเรามี
10 บิต X1 ถึง X10
นั่นหมายความว่าเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของ 10 บิตรวมกัน
ซึ่งอาจจะคิดเป็นรีจิสเตอร์ 10 บิต
ในคอมพิวเตอร์ เป็นต้น
คือผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนสิบชั้น
ของตัวอักษรไบนารีกับตัวมันเอง
แล้วถ้าเราเขียนสถานะเหล่านั้นเป็นสตริง มันจะดูแบบที่เห็น
ตรงนี้ มีทั้งหมด 1,024 อัน
ดังนั้นแน่นอนว่าไม่ได้แสดงทั้งหมดตรงนี้ จุดสามจุดตรงนี้
หมายถึงว่ามีรูปแบบที่สามารถคาดเดาได้
แล้วก็หวังว่าเข้าใจแนวคิดนะ ทีนี้มีข้อตกลง
ที่เราจะปฏิบัติตามสำหรับการเรียงลำดับสมาชิก
ของเซตผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
แล้วสำคัญที่ต้อง
ชี้แจงเรื่องนี้เพื่อการแทนทั้งสถานะความน่าจะเป็นและสถานะควอนตัมเป็นเวกเตอร์
ข้อตกลงคือ
เราเรียงลำดับสมาชิกของเซต
ผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนแบบพจนานุกรม ซึ่งก็คือ
การเรียงตามลำดับพจนานุกรมนั่นเอง
ให้เจาะจงมากขึ้น เราเริ่มจากข้อสมมติว่าแต่ละเซตที่เราเอามาทำผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนนั้นมีการเรียงลำดับของตัวเองอยู่แล้ว
แล้วเราก็คิดว่า
n-tuple หรือสตริงที่ให้มาเหมือนว่ามันเป็นคำ แล้วเรา
เรียงลำดับตามตัวอักษร
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดคือ ตำแหน่งภายใน
n-tuple หรือสตริงจะลดความสำคัญ
จากซ้ายไปขวา
เหมือนตอนที่เราเขียนตัวเลขโดยใช้หลักศูนย์ถึงเก้า
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่
ช่วยให้เข้าใจชัดขึ้น
ถ้าเราเอาผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนระหว่างเซตที่มี
หนึ่ง สอง แล้วก็สาม กับตัวอักษรไบนารี เราจะได้เซตที่มีหกสมาชิก
แล้วตรงนี้ก็แสดงรายการตาม
ลำดับที่กำลังอธิบาย
สมาชิกทุกตัวที่มี
หนึ่งอยู่ในตำแหน่งแรกมาก่อนสมาชิกทุกตัวที่มีสองอยู่ในตำแหน่งแรก แล้วก็มาก่อนสมาชิกทุกตัว
ที่มีสามอยู่ในตำแหน่งแรก แล้วเมื่อสองสมาชิก
ตรงกันในตำแหน่งแรก เราก็ย้อนกลับไปดูลำดับ
ในตำแหน่งที่สอง
นั่นคือลำดับที่
เราใช้สำหรับผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
สังเกตว่าเมื่อเราใช้ข้อตกลงนี้แล้วเขียน n-tuple เป็นสตริง เราจะเห็นรูปแบบที่คุ้นเคยมาก
ตัวอย่างเช่น ผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของ
ตัวอักษรไบนารีกับตัวมันเองเรียงลำดับแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้
แล้วก็สามารถคิดว่าสตริงเหล่านี้เรียงตามตัวเลข ถ้าเอาสตริงเหล่านี้
เป็นการเข้ารหัสไบนารีของจำนวนเต็มไม่ติดลบ
แล้วมันก็ขยายผลได้
สำหรับสตริงความยาวเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ ไปต่อเรื่องสถานะความน่าจะเป็น เรารู้จากบทเรียนที่แล้วแล้ว
ว่าสถานะความน่าจะเป็นจะกำหนดค่าความน่าจะเป็นให้กับแต่ละสถานะ
คลาสสิกของระบบที่กำหนด
ถ้าเรามีระบบประกอบที่เราเอาสองระบบหรือมากกว่ามารวมกัน แล้วมองรวมกันเหมือนว่ามันเป็นระบบ
เดียวอย่างที่เราเพิ่งพูดถึง
สถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ของระบบประกอบนี้ต้องกำหนดค่าความน่าจะเป็นให้กับสมาชิกของผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
ของระบบแต่ละตัว
เซตสถานะคลาสสิก นั่นเป็นเพราะว่ามัน
คือเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบประกอบ
ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติ
ว่า X กับ Y เป็นบิต เรามีตัวอย่างนี้ของ
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ XY
ความน่าจะเป็นที่ทั้ง
สองบิตเป็นศูนย์คือครึ่งหนึ่ง แล้วความน่าจะเป็นที่ทั้ง
สองบิตเป็นหนึ่งก็คือครึ่งหนึ่ง ดังนั้นสองบิตนี้ไม่เคยไม่ตรงกัน
มันเป็นสถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ถูกต้องของ XY แล้วเราก็สามารถ
เขียนเป็นเวกเตอร์ได้
แบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ แล้วตรงนี้จะเห็นว่าเรา
ปฏิบัติตามข้อตกลงที่ผมอธิบายเมื่อสักครู่สำหรับการเรียงลำดับสถานะคลาสสิกเหล่านี้
นี่เป็นตัวอย่างของ
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ X กับ Y มีความสัมพันธ์กัน แล้วนี่ก็เป็นความหมายที่ว่าส่วนรวม
ยิ่งใหญ่กว่าผลรวมของส่วนประกอบ อย่างที่บอกไปก่อนหน้านี้ มันไม่ใช่แค่ว่าเรา
มีสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ของ X กับสถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ Y แล้วเอามารวมกัน แต่เราเอา
ระบบมารวมกันก่อน
แล้วค่อยคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของระบบประกอบ
ให้แม่นยำยิ่งขึ้นเกี่ยวกับ
ความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างระบบ เราเริ่มด้วยการนิยาม
แนวคิดของความเป็นอิสระ ซึ่งโดยพื้นฐาน
คือการไม่มีความสัมพันธ์
ตรงนี้ คำว่าความเป็นอิสระหมายถึง
ความเป็นอิสระทางสถิติ ไม่ใช่ความเป็นอิสระเชิงเส้น
ของเวกเตอร์ เป็นต้น
มันเป็นแนวคิดพื้นฐานใน
ความน่าจะเป็นและสถิติ
ถ้าเรามีสองระบบ X กับ Y แล้วเรามีสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นบางอันของ XY อยู่ในใจ เราจะบอกว่า X กับ Y เป็นอิสระ
ถ้าสูตรที่
เห็นตรงนี้เป็นจริงสำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของสถานะ
คลาสสิก a กับ b ของ X กับ Y
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการตีความ
เงื่อนไขของความเป็นอิสระคือ มันบอกว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่ X จะอยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิกใดก็ตาม
กับความน่าจะเป็นที่ Y จะอยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิกอื่นนั้น ไม่เกี่ยวข้อง
กันเลย
ดังนั้น การรู้ว่าสถานะ
ของระบบหนึ่งเป็นอะไรไม่ส่งผลต่อ
ค่าความน่าจะเป็นที่เกี่ยวกับสถานะของระบบอีกตัว
ถ้าจินตนาการว่าสุ่มเลือก
สถานะคลาสสิกบางอันของ X ตามขั้นตอนอะไรสักอย่าง แล้วสุ่มเลือก
สถานะคลาสสิกบางอันของ Y
ตามขั้นตอนอื่นที่ไม่เกี่ยวข้อง
กับ X เลย เช่นถ้าคนหนึ่งโยนเหรียญ
แล้วอีกคนใน
ห้องอื่นทอยลูกเต๋า นี่ก็คือสูตร
ที่จะใช้คำนวณค่าความน่าจะเป็น
สำหรับค่าผสมต่างๆ
ของสถานะที่จะปรากฏ ประเด็นของนิยามคือ ความเป็นอิสระคือ
เมื่อสูตรนี้ใช้ได้
เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับสถานะความน่าจะเป็นในรูปของเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น จะมีการกำหนดสูตร
ของเงื่อนไขนี้อย่างง่าย
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรามี
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ XY ซึ่งเราสามารถเขียนเป็น
เวกเตอร์ในสัญกรณ์ Dirac
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ การบอกว่า X กับ Y เป็นอิสระนั้นเทียบเท่ากับการมีอยู่
ของเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นสองตัว
cat Phi กับ cat Psi ซึ่ง เราสามารถ
อ่านสั้นๆ ว่า Phi กับ Psi ที่แทน
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ X กับ Y แยกกัน ที่ทำให้สมการนี้
ที่เห็นตรงนี้เป็นจริง
สำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของ a กับ b มันเป็น
การเขียนนิยามใหม่ในรูปของเวกเตอร์
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นของคู่บิต XY ที่ X กับ Y เป็นอิสระ
เงื่อนไขที่
จำเป็นสำหรับความเป็นอิสระเป็นจริงสำหรับเวกเตอร์
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
คือ ความน่าจะเป็น
สำหรับแต่ละค่าที่เป็นไปได้ของสองบิตนั้นให้โดยผลคูณของค่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่สอดคล้องกันของแต่ละบิต
ตัวอย่างเช่น ความน่าจะเป็นที่ทั้ง
สองบิตจะมีค่าศูนย์เท่ากับหนึ่งส่วนหก ซึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่ง
ส่วนสี่คูณสองส่วนสาม
แล้วก็เหมือนกันสำหรับ
อีกสามกรณีที่เป็นไปได้ ซึ่งสามารถตรวจสอบทีละอัน
สำหรับสถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้านี้ ซึ่ง
เรามีสองบิตที่ตรงกันเสมอ แล้วมีค่าศูนย์กับ
หนึ่งด้วยความน่าจะเป็นครึ่งหนึ่ง
เราไม่มีความเป็นอิสระ แล้วนั่นเป็นเหตุผลที่เราบอกว่า
บิตทั้งสองมีความสัมพันธ์กัน
ความสัมพันธ์ก็แค่หมายถึง
การไม่มีความเป็นอิสระ
วิธีง่ายๆ ในการโต้แย้งว่า
สองบิตไม่เป็นอิสระคือ สมมติว่ามันเป็นอิสระ แล้วหาข้อขัดแย้ง
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าสอง
บิตเป็นอิสระ จะต้องมี
ตัวเลข q0, q1, r0 กับ r1
ที่แทนค่าความน่าจะเป็น
สำหรับแต่ละบิตแยกกัน เพื่อให้สมการ
ตรงนี้เป็นจริง
นี่คือค่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่มาจากเวกเตอร์ของเรา แล้วนี่คือ
สมการที่ต้องเป็นจริงตามเงื่อนไขของความเป็นอิสระ
แต่ถ้าเราดูที่
สมการที่สองตรงนี้ เราจะเห็นว่ามันต้องการให้
q0 คูณ r1 เท่ากับศูนย์
แต่วิธีเดียวที่
ผลคูณของจำนวนจริงสองตัวจะเท่ากับศูนย์ได้ คืออย่างน้อยหนึ่งในตัวเลข
เหล่านั้นต้องเท่ากับศูนย์เอง
บางทีเรียกว่า
สมบัติผลคูณเป็นศูนย์ของจำนวนจริง
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดคือ ผลคูณของจำนวนจริงที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์สองตัว
จะไม่เป็นศูนย์เสมอ
ดังนั้นสมการตรงนี้
บอกเป็นนัยว่า q0 เท่ากับศูนย์ หรือ r1 เท่ากับศูนย์
แต่จากสมการแรกกับสมการสุดท้าย เราเห็นว่าทั้ง
สองทางเลือกนั้นเป็นไปไม่ได้
ถ้า q0 เท่ากับศูนย์ ผลคูณนี้ต้องเท่ากับศูนย์ แต่มันไม่ได้เท่ากับศูนย์
แล้วถ้า r1 เท่ากับศูนย์
ผลคูณนี้ต้องเท่ากับศูนย์ แต่นั่นก็ไม่จริงเช่นกัน
ดังนั้นเรามีข้อขัดแย้ง
แล้วก็สรุปว่า X กับ Y ไม่เป็นอิสระ ดังนั้นมันมีความสัมพันธ์กัน
แนวคิดของความเป็นอิสระ
ที่เราเพิ่งพูดถึง โดยเฉพาะการกำหนดสูตรในรูปของเวกเตอร์
ความน่าจะเป็นนั้นเกี่ยวข้อง
กับการดำเนินการที่
ทำกับเวกเตอร์ได้ ที่เรียกว่า tensor product
Tensor product สามารถ
นิยามได้ไม่ใช่แค่สำหรับเวกเตอร์ แต่สำหรับเมทริกซ์ด้วย
และจริงๆ แนวคิดของ tensor product สามารถนิยามได้
สำหรับวัตถุทางคณิตศาสตร์
อีกหลายชนิดด้วย
มันสามารถอธิบาย
ในแบบนามธรรมพอสมควรที่ทั้งสำคัญและ
มีประโยชน์ในคณิตศาสตร์บริสุทธิ์ แต่เราสามารถนิยาม
tensor product สำหรับเวกเตอร์
ในแบบที่ง่ายและเป็นรูปธรรมมาก แล้วนั่นเป็นเส้นทางที่
เราจะใช้ในบทเรียนนี้
ถ้าเรามีเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์สองตัว Phi กับ Psi ที่เขียนในรูปแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดย sigma กับ gamma เป็น
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกใดๆ ก็ได้
ที่เราต้องการ หรือดัชนีถ้าชอบแบบนั้น tensor product ของเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้คือเวกเตอร์ที่เห็นตรงนี้
เราไล่ทุกสมาชิก
ของผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของสองเซต sigma กับ gamma แล้วค่าของเวกเตอร์นี้
ที่สอดคล้อง
กับแต่ละคู่ ab ซึ่ง
เขียนเป็นสตริงตรงนี้ เท่ากับผลคูณของ
ค่าที่สอดคล้องกัน
ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้ พูดอีกอย่างคือ ค่า ab ของ Phi tensor Psi คือผลคูณของค่า a
ของ Phi กับค่า b ของ Psi
แล้วนั่นคือความหมาย
ของสิ่งที่เขียนตรงนี้
โดยพื้นฐาน นี่คือการดำเนินการเดียวกันที่เราเห็นเมื่อสักครู่ตอนพูดถึงความเป็นอิสระ
แล้วตอนนี้เราแค่ตั้งชื่อให้มัน
นี่คือตัวอย่างเดียวกันเป๊ะ
ที่เราเห็นเมื่อสักครู่ เขียนอย่างชัดเจนมากขึ้นใน
รูปของ tensor product
อีกครั้ง เรามีหนึ่งส่วนหกเท่ากับหนึ่งส่วนสี่คูณหนึ่งส่วนสาม หนึ่งส่วนสิบสองเท่ากับหนึ่งส่วนสี่
คูณหนึ่งส่วนสาม แล้วก็ต่อไป
ตรงนี้ นี่คือ
วิธีทางเลือกสองสามแบบในการเขียน tensor
product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัว
เมื่อเราใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac แล้วเขียน cat สองตัว
ไว้ข้างกันแบบนี้ มันหมายถึง tensor product
ก็เลยคิดว่า tensor product เหมือนเป็นวิธีมาตรฐานในการคูณเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์สองตัวเข้าด้วยกัน
มันไม่สมเหตุสมผล
ที่จะคิดเรื่องผลคูณของเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์แบบนี้ในรูปของการคูณเมทริกซ์ เพราะมิติไม่ถูก
ดังนั้นไม่ต้องกังวล
เรื่องความกำกวมตรงนี้
เราสามารถเขียน
tensor product แบบนี้ข้างในของ cat แล้วก็หมายความ
เหมือนกันเป๊ะ
มันคือ tensor product
ของเวกเตอร์สองตัว
แบบแรกพบเห็นบ่อยมาก แล้วจริงๆ อาจจะพบเห็นการเขียน tensor product แบบนี้โดยไม่มีสัญลักษณ์ tensor product บ่อยกว่า
แบบที่มีสัญลักษณ์ แบบที่สอง
พบเห็นน้อยกว่ามาก แต่บางทีก็ช่วยได้มาก เป็นหลัก
เพื่อลดความจำเป็นของ
วงเล็บเพิ่มเติมในบางสถานการณ์
เราสามารถเขียน
tensor product อย่างชัดเจนในรูปของคอลัมน์ตัวเลข
จริงๆ อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ถ้าเราเอา tensor product ของเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์สองตัวตรงนี้ นี่คือเวกเตอร์ที่เราได้
แล้วจะเห็นว่าค่าตรงนี้เป็นผลคูณของค่า
ที่มาจากเวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้
การเรียงลำดับของค่า
ของ tensor product สอดคล้องกับ
นิยามจากเมื่อสักครู่ ตราบใดที่เราปฏิบัติตามข้อตกลง
ที่ผมอธิบายก่อนหน้าสำหรับการเรียงลำดับสมาชิก
ของเซตผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
การปฏิบัติตามข้อตกลงนั้นเทียบเท่ากับการคิด
ว่าดัชนีของเวกเตอร์แรกมี
ความสำคัญสูงกว่าดัชนีของเวกเตอร์ที่สอง
จะเห็นว่าเมื่อ
เราไล่ค่าของ tensor product เราจะมีผลคูณทั้งหมดที่เกี่ยวกับค่าแรกของ
เวกเตอร์แรกทางซ้าย
ซึ่งคือ alpha หนึ่ง จากนั้นก็ผลคูณทั้งหมด
ที่เกี่ยวกับค่าที่สองของเวกเตอร์ทางซ้าย
ซึ่งคือ alpha สอง แล้วก็ต่อไป
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่
เวกเตอร์ทางซ้ายมีสามค่า แล้วเวกเตอร์
ทางขวามีสี่ค่า เพื่อให้เห็นชัดขึ้น
ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
เรามีสามค่าในเวกเตอร์แรก ดังนั้นเราเริ่มด้วยการเขียนสำเนาสามชุดของเวกเตอร์ที่สอง แล้วเราคูณแต่ละสำเนา
ด้วยค่าที่สอดคล้องกัน
ในเวกเตอร์แรกแบบนี้
เรานำ alpha เข้าไปข้างในแบบนี้ แล้วตรงนี้เราก็แค่
คูณเวกเตอร์ด้วยสเกลาร์
แล้วสุดท้ายเราก็เอา
วงเล็บออกจากสำเนาแล้วรวมเป็นเวกเตอร์
คอลัมน์เดียวอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
เรื่องสำคัญที่ต้องทราบ สังเกตว่าเรามีสูตรต่อไปนี้สำหรับ tensor product ของ
เวกเตอร์ standard basis
ถ้าเราเอา tensor
product ของ cat a กับ cat b ซึ่งเราสามารถเขียนด้วย
สัญลักษณ์ tensor product หรือไม่ก็ได้ อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ผลลัพธ์ก็แค่ cat ab
ถ้าเราต้องการเขียน ab เป็นคู่อันดับแทนสตริง ก็ทำได้ แล้วเราจะได้
สำนวนตรงนี้
แต่พบเห็นบ่อยกว่ามากที่จะ
เขียนตรงนี้ ที่เราละวงเล็บ
แต่เหลือจุลภาค
มีความรู้สึกว่า
อันที่มีวงเล็บอาจจะถูกต้องกว่า แต่เป็นข้อตกลงมาตรฐาน
ในคณิตศาสตร์
ที่วงเล็บจะถูกตัดออกเมื่อไม่จำเป็นหรือไม่ได้ช่วยอะไร
คิดว่าวงเล็บมันซ่อนอยู่ตรงนี้ แล้วก็แค่ดูไม่รกกว่า
แล้วก็ดูดีกว่า
Tensor product มี
สมบัติสำคัญอย่างหนึ่งคือมันเป็น bilinear แล้วหมายความว่ามันเป็นเชิงเส้น
ในแต่ละอาร์กิวเมนต์สองตัว ตราบใดที่อีกตัวคงที่
ลงรายละเอียดอีกหน่อย มัน
เป็นเชิงเส้นในอาร์กิวเมนต์แรก ซึ่งแสดงด้วยสมการสองข้อที่เห็นตรงนี้
ข้อแรกบอกว่า
ถ้าเราบวกเวกเตอร์สองตัว Phi1 กับ Phi2 แล้วเอา
tensor product กับ Psi เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์เดียวกันกับที่
เอา tensor product
กับ Psi ก่อน แล้วค่อยบวก
ข้อที่สองบอกว่า ถ้า
เราคูณเวกเตอร์ Phi ด้วยสเกลาร์ alpha แล้วเราเอา
tensor product กับ Psi
ผลลัพธ์จะเหมือนกับถ้าเราเอา tensor product ของ Phi กับ Psi ก่อน แล้วค่อยคูณผลลัพธ์ด้วย alpha
แล้วเราก็มีความเป็นเชิงเส้น
ในอาร์กิวเมนต์ที่สองด้วย ซึ่งเหมือนกัน แค่สลับบทบาทของสองอาร์กิวเมนต์
สมบัติ bilinear นี้
ตรวจสอบจากนิยามได้ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมา แต่ดีที่จะเขียนออกมาแบบนี้เพราะเราจะใช้
สูตรเหล่านี้บ่อย
สังเกตว่าสเกลาร์ลอยผ่าน tensor product ได้อิสระ ในแบบที่แสดงด้วย
สมการที่เห็นตรงนี้
คือไม่มีความแตกต่าง
ระหว่างการคูณอาร์กิวเมนต์แรกด้วย
สเกลาร์ alpha ในกรณีนี้ การคูณอาร์กิวเมนต์ที่สอง
ด้วยสเกลาร์นั้น
หรือการคูณทั้งหมด
สมการเหล่านี้ตามมาจาก
สมการสองข้อตรงนี้ แล้วเพราะไม่มี
ความแตกต่างระหว่างเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ เราก็เขียน
สำนวนแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ได้
โดยไม่มีวงเล็บเพราะ
ไม่จำเป็นต้องมี
มันไม่ได้เพิ่มความชัดเจน
หรือลดความกำกวม ดังนั้นเราก็แค่เอาออกแล้ว
ได้สำนวนที่สะอาดขึ้น
ทั้งหมดนี้ขยายผลได้
สำหรับสามระบบหรือมากกว่า
เราสามารถนิยาม tensor product
ของเวกเตอร์สามตัวหรือมากกว่า โดยขยายผลสูตร
ของ tensor product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวในแบบธรรมชาติ
ซึ่งเห็นได้ตรงนี้ แต่ละค่าของ tensor product ให้โดยผลคูณของ
ค่าที่สอดคล้องกัน
ของเวกเตอร์ที่เรา
กำลังเอา tensor product
อีกวิธีหนึ่งที่เทียบเท่ากัน
ในการนิยาม tensor product ของเวกเตอร์สามตัวหรือมากกว่า
คือทำแบบเรียกซ้ำ โดยย้อนกลับไปใช้นิยาม
ของ tensor product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์สองตัว ดังนั้นถ้า n เป็นอย่างน้อยสาม เราสามารถคิดว่า
tensor product ของ n เวกเตอร์
Phi1 ถึง Phi n คือ tensor product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์ที่ได้จาก
การเอา tensor product ของ n ลบหนึ่งตัวแรก
กับเวกเตอร์ตัวสุดท้าย
แล้วถ้าต้องการรู้ว่า
tensor product ของ n ลบหนึ่งเวกเตอร์แรกคืออะไร ก็ใช้สูตร
อีกครั้ง ในกรณีที่ n ลบหนึ่ง
เป็นอย่างน้อยสาม หรือใช้นิยาม
จากก่อนหน้าถ้า n ลบหนึ่งเท่ากับสอง
สองวิธีในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
tensor product ของเวกเตอร์สามตัวหรือมากกว่านั้นเทียบเท่ากัน
คราวนี้เมื่อเรามี
เวกเตอร์สามตัวหรือมากกว่าที่เราเอา tensor product เราไม่ใช้คำว่า bilinear
เราใช้คำว่า multilinear แทน
แต่แนวคิดเหมือนกัน
Tensor product เป็นเชิงเส้น
ในแต่ละตำแหน่ง ตราบใดที่เวกเตอร์ใน
ตำแหน่งอื่นทั้งหมด
คงที่ ไปต่อเรื่องการวัด
หลายระบบในสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
เราได้ข้อกำหนดสำหรับวิธีที่การวัด
ทำงานสำหรับหลายระบบทันที โดยแค่คิดว่ามัน
รวมกันเป็นระบบเดียว
ตราบใดที่ทุกระบบ
ถูกวัดหมด
ตัวอย่างง่ายๆ สมมติว่าเรามีสอง
บิต X กับ Y แล้วรวมกันอยู่ในสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นตรงนี้
ที่เราเห็นมาก่อน เป็นธรรมชาติว่า ถ้าเราวัด
บิตทั้งสอง เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ 00
หมายถึงศูนย์สำหรับการวัดแรกกับศูนย์สำหรับการวัดที่สอง ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นครึ่งหนึ่ง แล้วเราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ 1,1
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นครึ่งหนึ่งเช่นกัน นั่นค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมา
โดยพื้นฐาน การวัดทุกระบบเทียบเท่ากับการวัด
ระบบประกอบทั้งหมด
ถ้าเราไม่ได้วัดทุก
ระบบ แต่เราแค่วัด
บางระบบ สถานการณ์ก็ไม่ได้
ชัดเจนทันทีขนาดนั้น
จำกัดความสนใจอีกครั้งไปที่กรณีแค่สอง
ระบบ เพื่อดูสาระของสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นใน
บริบทที่ง่ายที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้
เราสามารถถามคำถามต่อไปนี้ สมมติว่าเรามีสองระบบ X กับ Y ที่อยู่ด้วยกันเป็นคู่
ในสถานะความน่าจะเป็นบางสถานะ
จะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราวัด
แค่ X แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ Y?
เราสามารถตอบคำถามนี้ได้โดยใช้ทฤษฎีความน่าจะเป็นพื้นฐาน
อย่างแรก เรารู้ว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัด
จะให้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะนั้นต้องให้โดยสูตร
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
เราสามารถคิดว่าค่าความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับแต่ละสถานะ
คลาสสิกของคู่ XY เหมือนว่าเราวัดทั้งสอง แล้วรวมค่าความน่าจะเป็นทั้งหมด
ที่สอดคล้องกับ X อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิกใดก็ตาม
a ที่เราสนใจ
นั่นเป็นเหตุผลว่าทำไมผลรวมตรงนี้ถึงรวมแค่สถานะคลาสสิก b ของ Y
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สูตรนี้คือ ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะเห็นสถานะ
คลาสสิกเฉพาะของ X ถ้าเราวัดมัน
ต้องสอดคล้องกับความน่าจะเป็นที่จะเห็นสถานะนั้น ถ้า
เราวัด Y ด้วย แม้ว่าเราจะไม่ได้วัด
นั่นเป็นธรรมชาติและเข้าใจง่ายมาก ความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัด X จะให้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะไม่สามารถขึ้นอยู่กับว่า Y
ถูกวัดด้วยหรือไม่
โดยไม่คำนึงถึงผลลัพธ์
นั่นบอกเราว่า
ค่าความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ
ที่เป็นไปได้ของการวัดคืออะไร แต่จะเกิดอะไรขึ้นกับ Y หรือ
ความรู้ของเราเกี่ยวกับ Y จากผลนั้น?
คำตอบคือยังคง
อาจมีความไม่แน่นอนเกี่ยวกับสถานะของ Y จาก
การที่ได้วัด X
แล้วเห็นผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ แล้วความไม่แน่นอนนั้นแสดงด้วยสูตรตรงนี้สำหรับค่าความน่าจะเป็นแบบมีเงื่อนไข
ที่ Y อยู่ในสถานะ
คลาสสิกเฉพาะ b เมื่อ X อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิก
สถานะคลาสสิก a ใดก็ตาม
ที่เราวัดได้
ให้แม่นยำ ความน่าจะเป็นที่ Y
อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิก b เมื่อ X อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิก a
เท่ากับความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ X อยู่ใน a แล้ว Y อยู่ใน b หารด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่ X
อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิก a
ดังนั้นถ้าเราวัด X เราจะเห็น
สถานะคลาสสิกต่างๆ ด้วยค่าความน่าจะเป็นที่กำหนด
โดยสูตรตรงนี้
แล้วขึ้นอยู่กับว่าได้ผลลัพธ์อะไร เราอาจยังมีความไม่แน่นอนเกี่ยวกับสถานะคลาสสิกของ Y แล้ว
ความไม่แน่นอนนั้นสะท้อน
โดยสูตรตรงนี้
จริงๆ มีวิธีง่ายมาก
ในการพูดเรื่องนี้ใหม่ แล้วก็คำนวณ
สำหรับกรณีเฉพาะโดยใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac
แล้วมันเป็นแบบนี้
เราเริ่มด้วยการเขียน
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ XY เป็นเวกเตอร์แบบนี้ แล้ว
นี่เป็นแบบทั่วไป
ค่าต่างๆ แสดงด้วย Pab แล้วค่าเหล่านี้จะเป็นตัวเลขอะไรก็ได้ ตราบใดที่เวกเตอร์ทั้งหมด
เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
เราสามารถเขียน cat ab เป็น
tensor product อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ แล้วก็ใช้
ความเป็น bilinear ของ tensor product
โดยเฉพาะว่ามันเป็นเชิงเส้นในอาร์กิวเมนต์ที่สอง เพื่อเขียนเวกเตอร์นี้
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
สิ่งที่เราทำคือแยกเวกเตอร์ standard basis
ทางด้านซ้ายออกมา แล้วใส่อะไรก็ตามที่ต้องการ
ทางด้านขวา
เพื่อให้ได้แบบนั้น เพราะมันจะเผยให้เห็นว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเรา
วัดระบบแรก X
โดยเฉพาะ ความน่าจะเป็น
ที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ a คือผลรวมของค่าความน่าจะเป็นทั้งหมดที่อยู่ใน
วงเล็บข้าง cat a
แล้วเมื่อกำหนดเงื่อนไขว่า
ได้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ a เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นที่อธิบายความไม่แน่นอนที่เหลือเกี่ยวกับ Y
คือเวกเตอร์ที่อยู่ใน
วงเล็บข้าง a
แต่เราต้อง normalize มันเพื่อให้เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น แล้วก็คือว่า
เราต้องหารเวกเตอร์นั้น
ด้วยผลรวมของค่าในเวกเตอร์นั้นเพื่อให้ได้เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
ตรงนี้ ผลรวมนั้นรวมทุก
c ใน gamma แทนที่จะเป็น b แค่เพื่อใช้ชื่อตัวแปรอื่น เพื่อจะไม่มีความสับสน
เกี่ยวกับขอบเขตของ
ตัวแปร ถ้าจะพูด
ผลรวมในตัวเศษ
กับตัวส่วนควรมองเป็นคนละอัน แล้วเราก็หลีกเลี่ยงโอกาส
ที่จะสับสนเรื่องนี้
โดยใช้ตัวแปร
ต่างกันสำหรับผลรวมทั้งสอง
นี่คือตัวอย่างสั้นๆ เพื่อ
แสดงให้เห็นว่าทั้งหมดนี้ทำงานยังไง
สมมติ XY เป็นคู่บิตในสถานะความน่าจะเป็นตรงนี้ เพื่อเข้าใจว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
เมื่อเราวัดบิตแรก
แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับบิตที่สอง เราเขียนเวกเตอร์อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดย cat zero กับ cat
one ในตำแหน่งแรก
ถูกแยกออกมาตามที่
อธิบายเมื่อสักครู่
ความเป็นไปได้แรกคือ
ผลลัพธ์การวัดเป็นศูนย์ แล้วความน่าจะเป็น
ที่จะเกิดขึ้นคือผลรวมของค่าความน่าจะเป็น
ข้างในวงเล็บ
ที่ tensor กับ cat zero ดังนั้นเราได้หนึ่งส่วนสิบสองบวกหนึ่งส่วนสี่ ซึ่งเป็นหนึ่งส่วนสาม แล้ว
เมื่อมีเงื่อนไขว่าผลลัพธ์เป็นศูนย์
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นของ Y
กลายเป็นเวกเตอร์นี้ที่ normalize แล้ว หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือหารด้วยค่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่เราเพิ่งคำนวณ แล้วก็เราจะได้
เวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
ความเป็นไปได้ที่สองคือผลลัพธ์การวัดเป็นหนึ่ง แล้วการคำนวณก็
ทำในแบบคล้ายกัน โดยใช้เทอมที่สองในสำนวน
แทนที่จะเป็นเทอมแรก แล้วถ้าต้องการตรวจสอบรายละเอียด ก็ได้เลย อย่างเคยก็หยุดวิดีโอเพื่อให้ตัวเองมีเวลาทำ
ก็สามารถทำการคำนวณ
แบบเดียวกันเพื่อหาว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อ
วัด Y แทน X
เป็นวิธีเดียวกัน แค่มีสมมาตรระหว่างสองระบบ
คราวนี้เราเขียน
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นแบบนี้ แยกเวกเตอร์ standard basis ทางด้านขวาอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
แต่นอกจากนั้นก็ทำงาน
ในแบบเดียวกันเป๊ะ
ก็สามารถใช้วิธีนี้สำหรับ
มากกว่าสองระบบได้ด้วย
อาจจะยุ่งนิดหน่อย
ที่ต้องเขียนสำนวนที่จำเป็นทั้งหมด แต่ในเชิงแนวคิดมันเป็น
แนวคิดเดียวกันเป๊ะ
สุดท้าย สำหรับส่วนของบทเรียน
เรื่องข้อมูลคลาสสิก เรามาดูการดำเนินการ
กับสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ของหลายระบบ ตามเหตุผลเดียวกันที่เราเห็นมาสองสามครั้งแล้ว
เราสรุปได้ว่าการดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นบนหลายระบบก็เหมือน
กับการดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นบนระบบเดี่ยว ที่แทนด้วย
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก
แต่คราวนี้เมทริกซ์เหล่านั้น
มีแถวกับคอลัมน์ที่สอดคล้องกับผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของ
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกของแต่ละระบบ
คือเราแค่
มองระบบประกอบเหมือนว่ามันเป็นระบบเดียว แล้วย้อนกลับไปใช้คำอธิบายสำหรับวิธีที่การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นทำงาน
สำหรับระบบเดี่ยวจาก
บทเรียนที่แล้ว
นี่คือตัวอย่างของการดำเนินการที่เรียกว่า controlled-NOT
บนสองบิต X กับ Y
นี่เป็นการดำเนินการแบบดีเทอร์มินิสติก แล้ววิธีที่มันทำงานคือ
ถ้า X เท่ากับหนึ่ง จะทำการดำเนินการ NOT กับ Y
แล้วถ้า X เท่ากับ
ศูนย์ ก็ไม่เกิดอะไรขึ้น
บิต X บางทีเรียกว่า
บิตควบคุม เพราะมันกำหนดว่า
จะทำการดำเนินการ NOT กับ Y หรือไม่
แล้ว Y เรียกว่าบิตเป้าหมาย เพราะมันเป็นบิตที่ถูกกระทำโดยการดำเนินการ NOT
ก็สามารถจินตนาการ
ว่าสลับบทบาทของ X กับ Y เพื่อให้ Y เป็นบิต
ควบคุมแล้ว X เป็นเป้าหมาย แต่นั่นเป็นการดำเนินการคนละอัน
จากที่อธิบายตรงนี้ เพราะการดำเนินการไม่
สมมาตรระหว่าง X กับ Y
ทั้งสองเรียกว่า
การดำเนินการ controlled-NOT แล้วเราก็แค่ต้องระบุ
ว่าบิตไหนเป็นบิตควบคุมแล้ว
บิตไหนเป็นบิตเป้าหมาย
การดำเนินการนี้มีผลกระทบ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้ต่อสถานะ standard basis แล้วก็สามารถตรวจสอบ
ผลกระทบนั้นเทียบกับนิยาม
ของการดำเนินการ แล้วนี่คือ
การแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ของการดำเนินการ
เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการนี้ เราคิดว่ามี
สองบิตแยกกัน แล้วมันมีบทบาทที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย โดย
X เป็นบิตควบคุม
แล้ว Y เป็นบิตเป้าหมาย แต่จริงๆ ไม่มีอะไร
เกี่ยวกับผลกระทบตรงนี้ หรือการแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้
ที่บังคับให้เรา
ต้องคิดว่าสองบิตนี้เป็นบิตแยกกัน
เราก็อาจจะแค่
คิดว่าการดำเนินการนี้เป็นการดำเนินการ
แบบดีเทอร์มินิสติกบนระบบที่มีสี่สถานะคลาสสิก
ที่เราตัดสินใจตั้งชื่อว่า
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 แล้วก็ 1,1
นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง
ของการดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นบนสองบิต ซึ่งไม่ใช่การดำเนินการ
แบบดีเทอร์มินิสติกคราวนี้
การดำเนินการนี้ตั้ง Y ให้เท่ากับ X ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นครึ่งหนึ่ง แล้วไม่งั้นก็กลับทาง โดยตั้ง X ให้เท่ากับ Y
การดำเนินการนี้ไม่มีชื่อพิเศษ แค่เป็นตัวอย่าง
แล้วนี่คือ
การแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ของการดำเนินการนี้
จะเห็นว่ามันสามารถเขียนเป็นค่าเฉลี่ยของสองเมทริกซ์ อันหนึ่งแทน
การดำเนินการแบบดีเทอร์มินิสติก
ที่ Y ถูกตั้งเป็นค่า
อะไรก็ตามที่เก็บใน X แล้วอีกอันตั้ง
X ให้เท่ากับ Y
ตรงนี้เราเห็นว่าเราสามารถหาค่าเฉลี่ยของเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกเพื่อให้ได้อันใหม่ เหมือนที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนที่แล้ว
ทีนี้ ลองพิจารณา
คำถามต่อไปนี้ สมมติว่าเรามีสอง
การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็น แต่ละอันบนระบบของตัวเอง
ที่อธิบายตามปกติด้วยเมทริกซ์
สโตแคสติก แล้วให้แม่นยำ สมมติว่า M เป็น
การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็น
บนระบบ X แล้ว N เป็น
การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นบนระบบ Y
คำถามคือ ถ้าเรา
ทำ M บน X กับ N บน Y พร้อมกัน เราจะอธิบาย
ผลกระทบที่มันมี
ต่อระบบประกอบ XY ยังไง?
ลองคิดเรื่องนี้
ตามสัญชาตญาณสักครู่ ถ้าเราทำ
สองการดำเนินการพร้อมกันบนระบบของแต่ละอัน
เราก็กำลัง
ทำการดำเนินการบนระบบประกอบจริงๆ ดังนั้นมันควรอธิบาย
ด้วยเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกบางอัน
คำตอบสั้นๆ ของคำถามนี้
คือ เมทริกซ์ได้จากการเอา tensor product ไม่ใช่ระหว่างเวกเตอร์อย่าง
ที่เราพูดก่อนหน้า
แต่ระหว่างเมทริกซ์ ในกรณีนี้
คือเมทริกซ์ M กับ N
ดังนั้นเรามาใช้เวลาสักครู่
เพื่อพูดถึง tensor product ของเมทริกซ์ แล้วเราจะ
กลับมาที่คำถามนี้
นี่คือนิยาม
ของ tensor product ระหว่างเมทริกซ์ แล้ว
มันคล้ายกับ tensor product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์มาก
ถ้าเราสมมติว่าสอง
เมทริกซ์ที่เราทำงานด้วยเขียนในรูปแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดยค่าของ M
แสดงด้วย alpha ab เมื่อ a กับ b
ไล่ทุกค่าในเซตสถานะคลาสสิก sigma แล้วค่าของ N
แสดงด้วย beta cd เมื่อ c กับ d
ไล่ทุกค่าในเซตสถานะคลาสสิก gamma
tensor product ของ M กับ N คือเมทริกซ์ที่เห็นตรงนี้
สิ่งที่เรามีคล้ายกับ
tensor product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์
แถวกับคอลัมน์ของ M tensor N สอดคล้องกับคู่ของสถานะคลาสสิก ซึ่งเขียนเป็นสตริงตรงนี้
แล้วค่าต่างๆ คือผลคูณของค่าที่สอดคล้องกันของ M กับ N
นี่คืออีกวิธีหนึ่งในการเขียนมัน ในรูปของค่าแต่ละตัว
ของเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้
ค่า ac bd ของ M tensor N คือผลคูณของค่า ab
ของ M กับค่า cd ของ N
มีอีกวิธีหนึ่งในการ
อธิบาย M tensor N ก็คือมันเป็น
เมทริกซ์เดียวที่แปลงเวกเตอร์ในรูปแบบ Phi tensor Psi
ให้เป็น tensor product ของ M คูณ Phi กับ N คูณ Psi แล้วนั่นต้องเป็นจริงสำหรับทุกตัวเลือก
ของเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ Phi กับ Psi
อีกวิธีในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
เรื่องนี้คือ tensor product ของเมทริกซ์เข้ากันดีกับ tensor product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์
นี่เป็นสมการที่
เราหวังว่าจะเป็นจริง แล้วมันก็เป็นจริงด้วย
ในรูปของเมทริกซ์ที่
เขียนออกมาอย่างชัดเจน เราสามารถนิยาม tensor
product อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
มีจุดเยอะมากในสมการนี้ แล้วมันเพื่อ
แสดงรูปแบบ ซึ่งเป็นรูปแบบเดียวกัน
ที่เรามีสำหรับเวกเตอร์ แต่ตอนนี้เรามีแถวกับคอลัมน์
แทนที่จะเป็นแค่เวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
ในกรณีที่ไม่ชัด ตัวอย่าง
ต่อไปนี้อาจช่วยได้
ตรงนี้เราพูดถึง
tensor product ของเมทริกซ์สองคูณสองสองตัว
เราเริ่มด้วยเขียนสี่
สำเนาของเมทริกซ์ที่สอง หนึ่งอันสำหรับแต่ละค่าของเมทริกซ์แรก
เราคูณแต่ละ
สำเนาของเมทริกซ์ที่สองด้วยค่า
ที่สอดคล้องกันของเมทริกซ์แรก
แล้วก็รวบรวมทั้งหมดเข้า
เป็นเมทริกซ์สี่คูณสี่เดียวอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
เราสามารถนิยาม
tensor product ของเมทริกซ์สามตัวหรือมากกว่าในแบบคล้ายกัน แล้วก็วิธีที่ง่ายที่สุด
ในการเขียนนี้
เป็นอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
โดยเรามีสูตรสำหรับแต่ละค่าของ tensor product ซึ่งก็แค่ผลคูณ
ของค่าที่สอดคล้องกัน
ก็สามารถนิยาม tensor product ของเมทริกซ์สามตัวหรือมากกว่าแบบเรียกซ้ำ ในรูปของ tensor
product ของแค่สองเมทริกซ์ เหมือนที่เรามีสำหรับเวกเตอร์
แล้วหมายเหตุสุดท้ายคือ
tensor product ของเมทริกซ์มีสมบัติการคูณ ซึ่งหมายความว่าผลคูณ
ของ tensor product
เท่ากับ tensor
product ของผลคูณ
สามารถคิดว่า
นี่เป็นการขยายผลของสูตรจากเมื่อสักครู่สำหรับผลกระทบของ tensor
product ของเมทริกซ์
ต่อ tensor product ของเวกเตอร์ แล้วก็นี่เป็นสิ่งที่เรา
หวังว่าจะเป็นจริง แล้วเราก็ดีใจที่มันเป็นจริง
แล้วเราก็จะใช้
ข้อเท็จจริงนี้เมื่อจำเป็น
แล้วตอนนี้เราก็กลับมาที่
คำถามจากก่อนหน้า ที่ถามว่าเราอธิบาย
ผลกระทบของการทำ M บนระบบ X ยังไง
กับการดำเนินการ N บนระบบ Y ร่วมกัน เป็นการดำเนินการ
บนระบบประกอบ XY
แล้วคำตอบของคำถามนั้น
คือผลกระทบอธิบายด้วย
tensor product ของ M กับ N
Tensor product แทนความเป็นอิสระ คราวนี้ระหว่างการดำเนินการ ตรงข้ามกับที่เราเห็น
ก่อนหน้าสำหรับเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
นี่คือตัวอย่างสั้นๆ สมมติว่าเราทำ
การดำเนินการความน่าจะเป็นที่อธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์นี้บนบิต X
นี่เป็นการดำเนินการ
ที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง แล้วเราทำ
การดำเนินการ NOT บนบิต Y พร้อมกัน
การดำเนินการรวมบนคู่ XY จึงแทนด้วย tensor product ของเมทริกซ์ที่สอดคล้องกับสองการดำเนินการนี้
นี่คืออันบน X แล้ว
นี่คือการดำเนินการ NOT บน Y แล้วเราก็ได้เมทริกซ์
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
แล้วจะเห็นว่าจริงๆ
นี่เป็นเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก แล้วมันจะเป็นแบบนั้นเสมอ
Tensor product ของ
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกสองอัน หรือกี่อัน
ก็ตาม จะเป็นเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกเสมอ
เป็นสถานการณ์ที่พบบ่อยมาก
ที่เราเจอสถานการณ์ที่การดำเนินการหนึ่ง
ทำบนระบบหนึ่ง แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับอีกระบบ
ในสถานการณ์นี้ เราทำตามขั้นตอนเดียวกันเป๊ะ โดยเข้าใจว่าการไม่ทำอะไรแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรามีสองบิต X กับ
Y แล้วเรารีเซ็ตบิต X เป็นสถานะศูนย์ ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องเดียวกับ
การทำฟังก์ชันค่าคงที่
ศูนย์บน X แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ Y การดำเนินการผลลัพธ์บนคู่ XY
แทนด้วย tensor
product ตรงนี้
ทั้งหมดนี้ขยายผลได้
สำหรับจำนวนระบบเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ แล้วเราจะเห็นตัวอย่างเพิ่มเติมเมื่อเราไปถึงบริบทควอนตัม ซึ่งทำงานในแบบเดียวกันเป๊ะ
แต่เรามีเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีแทนเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก แล้วก็พอแค่นี้สำหรับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิกตอนนี้
ทีนี้เราจะหันความสนใจ
ไปที่ข้อมูลควอนตัมแล้วว่ามันทำงานยังไงสำหรับหลายระบบ
รูปแบบเหมือนกับที่เป็น
สำหรับข้อมูลคลาสสิก
เราสามารถมองหลายระบบควอนตัมเป็นระบบประกอบเดียว แล้วนำสิ่งที่เรารู้
จากบทเรียนที่แล้วมาใช้
อีกครั้ง tensor product
จะมีบทบาทสำคัญ แล้วโดยรวมเราจะได้คำอธิบายสำหรับวิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัม
ทำงานสำหรับหลายระบบ
ที่คล้ายกันมาก
แล้วก็คล้ายทางคณิตศาสตร์กับที่เราเพิ่งเห็น
สำหรับข้อมูลคลาสสิก
เราจะเริ่มด้วยสถานะควอนตัม
สถานะควอนตัมของหลายระบบแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ที่มีค่าเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
แล้วมีนอร์มยูคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง
เหมือนกับสถานะควอนตัม
ของระบบเดี่ยว
คราวนี้ดัชนีของ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมสอดคล้องกับผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของเซตสถานะคลาสสิก
ของระบบแต่ละตัว
เพราะอีกครั้ง นั่นคือ
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบประกอบ
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า X กับ Y เป็น qubit เซตสถานะ
คลาสสิกสำหรับคู่ XY ด้วยกันคือผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนของ
ตัวอักษรไบนารีกับตัวมันเอง
ซึ่งเราสามารถมองเป็น
เซตของสตริงไบนารีความยาวสองทั้งหมด
เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ที่เห็นตรงนี้เป็นตัวอย่างทั้งหมดของเวกเตอร์
สถานะควอนตัมของ XY
ถ้าต้องการ เราสามารถเขียน
เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้แบบนี้แทน โดยมี cat แยก
สำหรับแต่ละ qubit
โดยที่ tensor product
ระหว่างมันซ่อนอยู่
หรือเราก็สามารถเขียน
สัญลักษณ์ tensor product อย่างชัดเจนแบบนี้ถ้าชอบ
แล้วอีกตัวเลือกคือ
ใส่ตัวห้อยให้ cat ด้วยชื่อของระบบ
ที่มันแทนแบบนี้
แล้วก็ทำแบบนี้ได้ทั้ง
มีสัญลักษณ์ tensor product หรือไม่มี
นั่นบางทีก็ช่วยมากในการแยกแยะให้ชัดเจน
เหล่านี้แค่เป็นสไตล์ที่ต่างกันในการเขียนเวกเตอร์เดียวกัน แล้วเราก็เลือกแบบไหนก็ได้ที่ต้องการ หรือแบบที่ชอบ หรือ
แบบที่สมเหตุสมผลที่สุด
สำหรับสถานการณ์นั้น เมื่อสิ่งต่างๆ
ซับซ้อนขึ้น เป็นต้น เราอาจตัดสินใจว่า
สไตล์ใดสไตล์หนึ่งเพิ่มความชัดเจน
แล้วเราก็มีอิสระ
ที่จะเลือกแบบไหนก็ได้ที่ต้องการ
Tensor product ของเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมก็เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเช่นกัน
สำหรับกรณีสองระบบ เช่น ถ้า Phi เป็นเวกเตอร์
สถานะควอนตัมของระบบ X แล้ว Psi เป็นเวกเตอร์
สถานะควอนตัมของระบบ Y
tensor product ของ Phi กับ Psi เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของ XY
เราเรียกสถานะแบบนี้ว่าสถานะผลคูณ แล้วคล้ายกับที่เราเห็นในบริบทความน่าจะเป็นคลาสสิก มันแทนความเป็นอิสระ
ระหว่างระบบ X กับ Y
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าคนหนึ่งมีห้องปฏิบัติการ
ในส่วนหนึ่งของโลก แล้วสร้างระบบ X แล้วเริ่มต้นมันเป็นสถานะควอนตัม Phi
แล้วอีกคนใน
อีกส่วนของโลก เริ่มต้นระบบ Y เป็นสถานะควอนตัม Psi อย่างเป็นอิสระ
ถ้าเราเลือกที่จะคิดว่า XY รวมเป็นระบบเดียว แม้ว่าสองส่วนจะอยู่คนละส่วนของโลก
ระบบประกอบ XY ก็จะ
อยู่ในสถานะ Phi tensor Psi
ทั้งหมดนี้ขยายผลได้
สำหรับมากกว่าสองระบบในแบบธรรมชาติ
ถ้าเรามี
สถานะควอนตัม Psi1 ถึง PsiN ของระบบแยก Xn ถึง Xn tensor product ของ n เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้
แทนสถานะควอนตัม ที่เรียกว่าสถานะผลคูณอีกครั้ง ของระบบประกอบ X1 ถึง Xn
นี่คือตัวอย่างของ
สถานะควอนตัมของสอง qubit
แม้ว่าอาจจะ
ดูไม่ออกทันที มันเป็นตัวอย่างของสถานะผลคูณ เพราะเราสามารถเขียน
มันเป็น tensor product อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ดังนั้นมันเป็นตัวอย่าง
ของสถานะผลคูณ ไม่ว่าจะเขียนยังไง สิ่งที่สำคัญคือ
มันเป็นไปได้ที่จะเขียนมันเป็น tensor product หรือไม่
สถานะควอนตัมนี้ ซึ่งก็เป็นสถานะของสอง
qubit อีกเช่นกัน ไม่ใช่สถานะผลคูณ
มันคล้ายในจิตวิญญาณกับ
ตัวอย่างที่เราเห็นในบริบทความน่าจะเป็น ของบิตสุ่มสองตัวที่สัมพันธ์กันอย่างสมบูรณ์
แล้วอาร์กิวเมนต์เดียวกันเผยว่ามันไม่สามารถเขียน
เป็น tensor product ได้
ย้ายอันนี้มาตรงนี้แล้วมาดูอาร์กิวเมนต์ในรายละเอียดมากขึ้นสักหน่อย
ลองจินตนาการว่าเรา
สามารถเขียนสถานะนี้เป็น tensor product ของ
เวกเตอร์สองตัว Phi กับ Psi
ค่าที่สอดคล้อง
กับสถานะคลาสสิก 0,1 เป็นศูนย์สำหรับเวกเตอร์นี้ ซึ่งเราเห็นได้จากการดูมัน
แต่นี่จะบอกเป็นนัยว่า ถ้าเวกเตอร์เป็น tensor
product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัว ค่าศูนย์ของ Phi
คูณค่าหนึ่งของ Psi
จะเท่ากับศูนย์ แต่นั่นหมายความว่า
ค่าศูนย์ของ Phi หรือค่าหนึ่งของ Psi เท่ากับศูนย์
หรือทั้งสองอาจเท่ากับศูนย์ แต่นั่นขัดแย้งกับข้อเท็จจริง
ที่ว่าผลคูณสองตัวตรงนี้ต้องไม่เป็นศูนย์ทั้งคู่
มันเท่ากับหนึ่ง
ส่วนรากที่สองของสอง อาร์กิวเมนต์นี้จริงๆ แทบจะ
เหมือนกับที่เรามีในบริบทความน่าจะเป็น
ไม่มีอะไรที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์
ของควอนตัมเลยตรงนี้
ไม่ว่ายังไง สิ่งที่เราพบคือสถานะเดิมไม่ใช่สถานะผลคูณ
สังเกตว่าไม่สำคัญ
ที่ตัวเลขสองตัวนี้เป็นหนึ่งส่วนรากที่สองของสอง
สิ่งที่สำคัญแค่ว่า
ทั้งสองค่าไม่เป็นศูนย์
สถานะควอนตัมนี้
เป็นสถานะที่น่าสนใจมาก มันเป็นตัวอย่างของ
สถานะพัวพันของสอง qubit
เราจะพูดเรื่องการพัวพัน
เพิ่มเติมในภายหลังของซีรีส์
การพัวพันอาจซับซ้อน โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเรา
พูดถึงสถานะควอนตัมในสูตรทั่วไป
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
แต่ตรงนี้ในคำอธิบายแบบย่อของข้อมูลควอนตัม การพัวพันเทียบเท่ากับการไม่มีความเป็นอิสระ
ดังนั้นสำหรับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ถ้ามันไม่ใช่สถานะผลคูณ มันก็เป็นสถานะพัวพัน
แล้วสถานะนี้โดยเฉพาะ
มักถูกมองว่าเป็น
ตัวอย่างต้นแบบของสถานะควอนตัมพัวพัน
แล้วจริงๆ บางที
เราก็คิดว่าสถานะนี้แทนหนึ่งหน่วยของการพัวพัน โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับการพัวพัน
เป็นทรัพยากรที่สามารถ
ใช้ทำสิ่งที่น่าสนใจได้
สถานะควอนตัมที่
เราเพิ่งพูดถึงเป็นหนึ่งในสี่สถานะที่เรียกว่าสถานะ Bell ซึ่งเห็นได้ตรงนี้
พร้อมกับชื่อ
ที่ใช้กันทั่วไปสำหรับสถานะเหล่านี้ Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus แล้วก็ Psi minus
ทั้งหมดเป็นสถานะพัวพัน
แล้วก็เป็นฐานสำหรับปริภูมิของเวกเตอร์ทั้งหมด
ที่แทนสถานะของสอง qubit
เวกเตอร์สี่ตัวนี้รวมกัน
เรียกว่าฐาน Bell
เป็นชุดของ
สถานะควอนตัมที่พบเจอบ่อยมาก ตั้งชื่อ
เป็นเกียรติแก่ John Bell ซึ่งเป็นนักฟิสิกส์ที่มี
ผลงานสำคัญมาก
ต่อการศึกษาการพัวพันในทศวรรษ 1960
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่รู้จักกันดีสองสามอันของสถานะควอนตัมของสาม qubit
อันแรกเรียกว่าสถานะ GHZ
มันคล้ายกับสถานะ Phi
plus ที่เราเพิ่งเห็น แต่สำหรับสาม qubit แทนที่จะเป็นสอง
แล้วตัวอย่างที่สองเรียกว่าสถานะ W แล้วดูเหมือนที่เห็นตรงนี้ มันสม่ำเสมอทั่ว
สตริงไบนารีสามตัว
ความยาวสามที่มี
บิตเดียวเท่านั้นที่ตั้งเป็นหนึ่ง
ทั้งสองสถานะไม่ใช่สถานะผลคูณ แล้วทั้งสองมีสมบัติที่น่าสนใจแล้วก็ปรากฏบ่อยเป็นตัวอย่าง ดังนั้นรู้จักไว้ดี
แล้วเราจะเห็นมันอีก
ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง
การวัดระบบในสถานะควอนตัม
ตามเหตุผลเดียวกัน
ที่เราใช้มาตลอดในบทเรียนนี้ ซึ่งคือคิดว่าหลายระบบ
เหมือนว่าเป็นระบบเดี่ยว เราก็ได้คำอธิบายสำหรับวิธีที่การวัด
หลายระบบควอนตัมทำงาน
ตราบใดที่ทุก
ระบบถูกวัดหมด
คือ ถ้าเรามี
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม Psi ที่แทน
สถานะควอนตัมของ n-tuple ระบบ
X1 ถึง Xn แล้วเราวัด
ระบบประกอบทั้งหมด ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับการวัด
ทุกระบบแต่ละตัว แล้ว n-tuple ของสถานะคลาสสิกแต่ละตัว
ที่เป็นไปได้จะเป็นผลลัพธ์ของการวัด
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของค่าของ Psi ที่
สอดคล้องกับ n-tuple นั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรามี
คู่ระบบ XY ในสถานะควอนตัมตรงนี้ แล้วถ้าเราวัดทั้งสองระบบ
เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ ศูนย์โพดำ หมายถึงศูนย์สำหรับการวัด X แล้วโพดำสำหรับการวัด Y
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเก้าส่วนยี่สิบห้า แล้วเราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ หนึ่ง
โพดำ ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสิบหกส่วนยี่สิบห้า
นั่นค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมา เราก็แค่ไม่สนใจข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่ามันเป็นสองระบบแยก แล้วมองว่ามัน
เป็นระบบเดียว
แต่นี่ก็ทำให้เกิด
คำถามที่เป็นธรรมชาติต่อไปนี้ ซึ่งเราพิจารณาแล้ว
ในบริบทคลาสสิก
สมมติว่าเรามีสองระบบ X กับ Y ที่รวมกัน
อยู่ในสถานะควอนตัมบางสถานะ แล้วเราไม่ได้วัดทั้งสอง แต่
เราวัดแค่ระบบเดียว
สมมติว่าเราวัดระบบ X แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ Y
แน่นอน เราก็ถามได้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเราวัด Y แล้วไม่ได้
วัด X แล้วก็โดยทั่วไปเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้าเรามี
สามระบบหรือมากกว่า
แล้ววัดเซตย่อยแท้บางเซตของมัน แต่เมื่อเรามี
คำตอบสำหรับคำถามนี้ เราก็จะมีคำตอบ
สำหรับคำถามเหล่านั้นด้วย
เรารู้ว่าโดยทั่วไป
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของคู่ XY อยู่ใน
รูปแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ สมมติตามปกติว่า sigma กับ gamma
เป็นเซตสถานะคลาสสิก
ของ X กับ Y ตามลำดับ
ค่าของเวกเตอร์นี้
แสดงด้วย alpha ab ที่ไล่ทุกตัวเลือกที่เป็นไปได้ของ a กับ b
แล้วมันเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนใดก็ได้ที่ทำให้เวกเตอร์นี้
เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
เรารู้แล้วว่า ถ้า
ทั้งสองระบบถูกวัด เราจะได้ค่าความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ ที่เป็นไปได้
โดยเอาค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของค่าที่สอดคล้องกัน
แล้วถ้าแค่ X ถูกวัด ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะ
ได้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ a ให้โดยสำนวนนี้
เราก็แค่รวมทุก
ผลลัพธ์ b ที่เป็นไปได้ ที่จะได้
ถ้า Y ถูกวัดด้วย แม้ว่าจะไม่ได้วัด
แนวคิดเหมือนกับใน
บริบทความน่าจะเป็น
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะ
ได้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะเมื่อ X ถูกวัด ไม่สามารถ
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า Y ถูกวัดด้วยหรือไม่
นี่ก็บอกเราว่า
ค่าความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ ที่เป็นไปได้คืออะไร
นอกจากนี้ จะมี
การเปลี่ยนแปลงสถานะของ Y เป็นผลจาก
การวัดนี้บน X แล้วได้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ
มาดูกันว่ามันทำงานยังไง
คล้ายกับที่เราทำใน
บริบทความน่าจะเป็น เราสามารถเขียน
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม Psi อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
โดยที่ Phi a คือเวกเตอร์นี้สำหรับแต่ละตัวเลือกของสถานะคลาสสิก a ของระบบ X
เราใช้ความเป็น bilinear
ของ tensor product เหมือนเดิม
แค่ว่าตอนนี้เราเลือกตั้งชื่อ
เวกเตอร์ต่างๆ เหล่านี้ว่า Phi a เพื่อความสะดวก
เราสังเกตแล้วว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัดจะให้
ผลลัพธ์แต่ละอัน a เป็นอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
แต่ตอนนี้เราเห็นว่าความน่าจะเป็นนี้เท่ากับนอร์มยูคลิด
ยกกำลังสองของเวกเตอร์ Phi a
แล้วตอนนี้จากผลของการวัด X ที่ให้ผลลัพธ์เฉพาะ a เราจะมีสถานะควอนตัม
ของระบบประกอบ XY
กลายเป็นสถานะที่
เห็นตรงนี้
เหมือนที่เรามีสำหรับระบบเดี่ยว สถานะยุบตัวลงในสาระ แต่มันไม่ได้ยุบ
ทั้งหมดโดยทั่วไป
มันยุบแค่เท่าที่จำเป็นเพื่อให้สอดคล้อง
กับการวัด X ที่ให้ผลลัพธ์ a
สถานะควอนตัมของ Y กลายเป็น Phi a ที่ normalize แล้ว หมายถึงว่าเรา
หารด้วยนอร์มยูคลิดของมัน
เพื่อให้มันกลายเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย นี่คล้ายกับสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นใน
บริบทความน่าจะเป็น ที่แทนที่จะหาร
ด้วยนอร์มยูคลิด
เราหารด้วยผลรวม
ของค่าของ Phi a เพื่อให้ได้เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
แต่ตรงนี้เพราะเรา
พูดถึงสถานะควอนตัม เราหารด้วยนอร์มยูคลิด
เพื่อให้ได้เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
มาดูตัวอย่างสองสามอันเพื่อดูว่ามันทำงานยังไง
สำหรับสถานะเฉพาะ
นี่คือสถานะที่เราจะพิจารณา เราสมมติว่า X กับ Y เป็น qubit แล้วมันอยู่ในสถานะ Psi เฉพาะนี้
แล้วสมมติว่า X ถูกวัด
เราเริ่มด้วยเขียนสถานะ
Psi อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดยแยกปัจจัย
standard basis ของ X ออกมา
แล้ว tensor มันกับอะไรก็ตามที่ต้องการเพื่อให้ได้สถานะเดิม
เหมือนกับใน
คำอธิบายทั่วไปจากเมื่อสักครู่
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์คือนอร์มยูคลิดยกกำลังสอง
ของเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
สิ่งที่เรา tensor กับ cat zero ในสำนวนของเวกเตอร์ Psi
ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นคือสามส่วนสี่ แล้วเมื่อมีเงื่อนไขว่า
ได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์
สถานะควอนตัมของ
คู่ XY กลายเป็นแบบนี้ โดยเรา normalize
เวกเตอร์ที่ tensor กับ cat zero
แล้วนั่นก็เทียบเท่ากับ
การหารด้วยรากที่สองของความน่าจะเป็น
ที่เราเพิ่งคำนวณ
เราสามารถทำให้ง่ายขึ้น
แล้วนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้
ผลลัพธ์การวัดเป็นหนึ่งก็คำนวณในแบบคล้ายกัน
เราเอานอร์มยูคลิดยกกำลังสอง
ของเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้ สิ่งที่ tensor กับ cat
one ในสำนวนของ Psi
แล้วค่าความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้
คือหนึ่งส่วนสี่ ซึ่งต้องเป็นแบบนั้นอยู่แล้ว เพราะค่าความน่าจะเป็น
ต้องรวมเป็นหนึ่ง
ในกรณีนี้ สถานะควอนตัมของ XY กลายเป็นแบบนี้ โดยเรา normalize อีกครั้งด้วยการหารด้วยนอร์มยูคลิด
เพื่อให้ได้เวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัมนี้เป็นผลลัพธ์
วิธีเดียวกันนี้ใช้
ในแบบสมมาตร ถ้า Y ถูกวัดแทน X
นี่คือเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเดิม แล้วคราวนี้เพราะ Y
ถูกวัดแทน X
เราเขียนเวกเตอร์ Psi
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดยคราวนี้เราแยกเวกเตอร์
standard basis ของ Y
แทน X แล้ว tensor
กับอะไรก็ตามที่ต้องการเพื่อให้ได้สำนวนของ Psi
ทำการคำนวณ ซึ่งตรวจสอบได้โดย
หยุดวิดีโอถ้าต้องการ
เราเห็นว่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์คือห้าส่วนแปดคราวนี้ แล้วนี่คือ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ที่ได้ เมื่อมีเงื่อนไข
ว่าได้ผลลัพธ์นั้น
แล้วความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้
ผลลัพธ์หนึ่งคือสามส่วนแปด ซึ่งในกรณีนั้นนี่คือ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของเรา
ก็สามารถใช้วิธีเดียวกันเป๊ะในกรณีที่มีมากกว่าสองระบบ แล้วเซตย่อยแท้ใดๆ
ของมันถูกวัด
แล้วก็มีตัวอย่าง
ในเนื้อหาตำราเรียนสำหรับบทเรียนนี้ที่
ลองดูได้ถ้าสนใจ
สรุปคือ เราสามารถแบ่งระบบออกเป็นสองกลุ่มแยกกันเสมอ อันที่ถูกวัด
กับอันที่ไม่ถูกวัด
แล้วเมื่อทำแบบนั้นแล้ว เราก็ย้อนกลับไปใช้
วิธีที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย แล้วนั่นคือวิธีที่การวัดสำหรับหลายระบบควอนตัมทำงาน
แล้วสุดท้าย เราก็ไปต่อที่การดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีบนหลายระบบ
ใช้แนวคิดพื้นฐานเดียวกันว่าหลายระบบสามารถมองเป็นระบบประกอบเดียว
เราสรุปได้ตามที่เห็น
เขียนบนหน้าจอ การดำเนินการควอนตัมบนระบบประกอบแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
เหมือนที่เรามีสำหรับระบบเดี่ยว โดยเฉพาะแถวกับคอลัมน์ของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีเหล่านั้นสอดคล้องกับผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียน
ของเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบอะไร
ก็ตามที่เราพูดถึง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรามีระบบ X
ที่สถานะคลาสสิกคือหนึ่ง สอง แล้วก็สาม แล้ว Y เป็น qubit
เมทริกซ์ที่เห็นตรงนี้เป็นตัวอย่างของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีที่แทน
การดำเนินการบนคู่ XY
รายละเอียดเรื่องวิธีที่เรา
เรียงลำดับผลคูณคาร์ทีเชียนที่เราพูดถึงก่อนหน้าไม่ได้สำคัญมาก
สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้ มันแค่เป็นเมทริกซ์หกคูณหก
ที่บังเอิญเป็นยูนิทารี
ไม่มีอะไรพิเศษเกี่ยวกับมัน แม้ว่ามันจะสร้าง
จากเมทริกซ์สำคัญสองสามตัว
ประเด็นคือ สามารถ
เลือกเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีหกคูณหกอันไหนก็ได้ แล้วมันจะแทน
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีบน XY
ถ้าเราใช้ชุดของ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีอย่างเป็นอิสระ แต่ละอันบนระบบของตัวเอง ผลกระทบรวมของทั้งหมด
บนระบบประกอบจะ
ให้โดย tensor product
แล้วตรงนี้บนหน้าจอจะเห็นข้อความ
ที่แม่นยำกว่าของข้อเท็จจริงนี้
ถ้าการดำเนินการยูนิทารีของเราอธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U1 ถึง Un หนึ่งอันสำหรับแต่ละระบบ
ผลกระทบรวม
บนระบบประกอบจะให้โดย tensor
product ของ U1 ถึง Un
อีกครั้ง คล้ายกับที่เรามีในบริบทความน่าจะเป็น ตัวอย่างสำคัญคือ
เราใช้การดำเนินการยูนิทารี
U บนระบบ X แล้วไม่ทำ
อะไรกับระบบอื่น Y
การดำเนินการบน XY ที่เราได้คือ U tensor กับเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
อธิบายการไม่ทำอะไรกับ Y
บางทีก็ช่วยที่จะเขียนอย่างชัดเจนว่าเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์นี้
สอดคล้องกับระบบ Y เพื่อให้สูตรชัดเจนขึ้น
แล้วตัวเลือกหนึ่งคือ
ใส่ตัวห้อยให้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์แบบนี้ ที่ระบุว่าระบบไหนที่มันกระทำ
เมื่อชัดเจนพอ เรามักจะไม่
ใส่ตัวห้อย แต่เมื่อสิ่งต่างๆ ซับซ้อนขึ้น มันก็ช่วยได้มาก
แล้วเราก็สามารถพิจารณา
กรณีสมมาตรที่ใช้การดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารี V บน Y แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ X
แล้วคราวนี้การดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีผลลัพธ์บน XY แทนด้วย tensor
product ตรงนี้
แล้วอีกครั้ง เราสามารถใส่ตัวห้อยให้
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ถ้ามันช่วย
นี่คือตัวอย่างเฉพาะสองสามอัน
ถ้า X กับ Y เป็น qubit แล้ว
เราทำการดำเนินการ Hadamard บน X แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ Y เราจะได้เมทริกซ์ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ถ้ากลับกัน เราทำการดำเนินการ Hadamard บน Y แล้วไม่ทำอะไรกับ X ลำดับของ tensor
product จะสลับกัน
แล้วเราจะได้เมทริกซ์
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ไม่ใช่ทุกการดำเนินการยูนิทารี
บนระบบประกอบจะเขียนเป็น tensor product ได้
ถ้าเรามี tensor product
เราก็มีความเป็นอิสระ
แล้วก็มีตัวอย่างพื้นฐาน
บางอันของการดำเนินการที่
ไม่ได้กระทำอย่างเป็นอิสระบนหลายระบบอย่างแน่นอน
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า X กับ Y มี
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกเหมือนกัน ซึ่งจะเป็น
เซตสถานะคลาสสิก sigma อะไรก็ได้
เราก็สามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การดำเนินการสลับบนคู่ XY
การดำเนินการนี้ไม่ได้เปลี่ยนลำดับของสองระบบ เรายังคงมี X อยู่
ซ้ายกับ Y อยู่ขวา แต่มันแทน
การสลับเนื้อหา
ของสองระบบ ตรงนี้จะเห็นมันเขียน
ในรูปแบบของสมการ โดยเรามี tensor
product ของสถานะควอนตัมสองตัว
อีกวิธีในการเขียนคือเป็น
เมทริกซ์อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
วิธีที่คิด
เกี่ยวกับคำอธิบายนี้คือ มันบอกว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นสำหรับเวกเตอร์ standard basis
แล้วเมื่อเรารู้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
สำหรับเวกเตอร์ standard basis เราก็รู้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นสำหรับ
สถานะควอนตัมใดๆ จากความเป็นเชิงเส้น
ซึ่งจริงๆ ก็เป็นจริงสำหรับ
สำนวนตรงนี้ด้วย
การดำเนินการเฉพาะนี้ตรงนี้เป็นการดำเนินการแบบดีเทอร์มินิสติกด้วย รวมถึงเป็นการดำเนินการยูนิทารี
ถ้า X กับ Y เป็น qubit เช่น เราจะได้
การแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้
นี่คือความเชื่อมโยงที่น่าสนใจ
ระหว่างการดำเนินการสลับกับสี่สถานะ Bell ซึ่งแสดง
ตรงนี้เพื่อความสะดวก
การดำเนินการสลับปล่อยให้
สามอันแรกเหมือนเดิม แต่ใส่เครื่องหมายลบหน้า
สถานะ Psi minus
ดังนั้นมีอะไรพิเศษ
เกี่ยวกับอันนั้น
ตรวจสอบสมการเหล่านี้ได้โดยตรง โดยดูที่เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้แล้วพิจารณาว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
สำหรับสถานะ standard basis
การสลับสถานะคลาสสิกสองตัวสำหรับสามสถานะ Bell
แรกไม่ทำอะไร เราก็ได้สถานะเดิมที่เราเริ่มต้น
แต่ในกรณีที่สี่ เครื่องหมายลบ
ย้ายจากเทอมหนึ่งไปอีกเทอมหนึ่งเมื่อเราทำการสลับสถานะคลาสสิก
แล้วนั่นก็เทียบเท่ากับการคูณเวกเตอร์ด้วยลบหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นการทำการดำเนินการสลับทำให้ปล่อยเครื่องหมายลบออกมา
จากสถานะ Bell ที่สี่นี้
เราจะมีเรื่องอีกเยอะที่จะพูดเกี่ยวกับ
สมการเหล่านี้ในภายหลัง แต่ตอนนี้ไปต่อที่
การดำเนินการอีกประเภทหนึ่ง ซึ่งก็คือการดำเนินการแบบควบคุม
เราจะสมมติว่า X เป็น qubit แล้ว Y เป็นระบบอะไรก็ได้ที่ต้องการ
ถ้า U เป็นการดำเนินการยูนิทารีบน Y การดำเนินการ controlled U บน XY คือการดำเนินการที่
เขียนตรงนี้
อย่างแรก ใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac แล้วก็ใช้สิ่งที่
เรียกว่าเมทริกซ์บล็อก ก็แค่จินตนาการว่าเติม
เมทริกซ์ที่ใหญ่กว่า
ด้วยเมทริกซ์ที่เล็กกว่า โดยศูนย์เหล่านี้แทนเมทริกซ์
ที่เต็มไปด้วยศูนย์จริงๆ
แต่ละบล็อกจากทั้งสี่บล็อกแทนเมทริกซ์ที่มีจำนวน
แถวกับคอลัมน์ที่ตรงกับจำนวน
สถานะคลาสสิกของ Y
แนวคิดของการดำเนินการแบบควบคุม ที่เราเจอแล้ว
ในบริบทคลาสสิกตอนพูดถึง
การดำเนินการ controlled-NOT
คือถ้า X ตั้งเป็นศูนย์
ก็ไม่เกิดอะไรขึ้นกับ Y
แต่ถ้า X ตั้งเป็นหนึ่ง
U ก็ถูกใช้กับ Y
X เรียกว่า qubit ควบคุม แล้ว Y เรียกว่าระบบเป้าหมาย ซึ่งโดยทั่วไปไม่
จำเป็นต้องเป็น qubit
สำหรับตัวอย่างเฉพาะ
ที่ผมเพิ่งกล่าวถึง เรามีการดำเนินการ controlled-NOT
ถ้า qubit แรกตั้งเป็น
ศูนย์ ไม่เกิดอะไร แล้วถ้า qubit แรกตั้งเป็นหนึ่ง การดำเนินการ NOT หรือพูดอีกอย่าง
การดำเนินการ sigma X ถูก
ใช้กับ qubit ที่สอง
แล้วนี่คือการแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ของมัน
เราพูดถึงสอง qubit ตรงนี้ ดังนั้นก็สามารถ
ตัดสินใจว่า qubit ที่สองเป็นตัวควบคุมแล้ว
ตัวแรกเป็นเป้าหมาย
เพื่ออธิบายการดำเนินการนั้น เราก็สลับลำดับ
ใน tensor product แล้วผลลัพธ์คือเมทริกซ์
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ถ้าแทนที่จะเป็นการดำเนินการ controlled-NOT เราพิจารณาการดำเนินการ controlled sigma
Z หรือ controlled Z
เราจะได้การแทนแบบ
เมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ แล้วสำหรับอันนี้ ไม่สำคัญจริงๆ
ว่าอันไหนเป็นตัวควบคุมแล้วอันไหนเป็นเป้าหมาย
เราได้ผลลัพธ์เดียวกันไม่ว่ายังไง
เราก็ไปไกลกว่านี้ได้ แล้วพิจารณาการดำเนินการ controlled swap
ตรงนี้เราพูดถึง
การสลับสอง qubit ดังนั้นเราลงเอยกับสาม qubit เมื่อรวม qubit ควบคุมด้วย
การแทนแบบเมทริกซ์
ดูเหมือนแบบนี้
เป็นการดำเนินการพิเศษมาก แล้วรู้จักกันในชื่อการดำเนินการ Fredkin หรือทั่วไปกว่าคือ Fredkin gate
เมื่อเราคิดว่ามัน
เป็น gate ใน circuit เราจะพูดถึง circuit ในบทเรียนถัดไป
ตัวอย่างสุดท้ายคือการดำเนินการ
controlled, controlled-NOT ซึ่งก็เป็น
การดำเนินการบนสาม qubit
แล้วนี่คือการแทนแบบเมทริกซ์ การดำเนินการนี้รู้จักกันดีกว่า
ในชื่อการดำเนินการ Toffoli หรือ Toffoli gate
เราจะพูดถึงมัน
เพิ่มเติม แล้วเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมทั้ง Toffoli กับ Fredkin gate ถึงเป็น
การดำเนินการที่สำคัญมากในบทเรียนถัดไป
แล้วนี่ก็คือจบบทเรียนที่สอง ในบทเรียนนี้ เราพูดถึงวิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานสำหรับหลายระบบ
หวังว่าจะมาร่วมกัน
ในบทเรียนที่สามเร็วๆ นี้ ซึ่งเป็นเรื่อง quantum circuit
โปรโตคอล แล้วก็เกม
ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะพบกันใหม่